[Music]
backing up a trailer gets people all
sorts of confused but it doesn't need to
be that hard it's really simple look at
this kid
okay you want the trailer to go left put
your hand on the bottom of this deal
with a steering wheel and go left once
the trailer to go right put your hand on
the bottom of the steering wheel and go
right okay don't put your hand up here
keep your hand down here and left is
left and right is right the longer the
trailer the less sensitive it is the
shorter the trailer the more sensitive
it is the last turn of the wheel you
need thanks for watching and hopefully
you like this video if you want to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel check out these great
videos and click Subscribe we put out
new videos every week thanks for
watching